sûrement les photos et vous
allez voir les photos de
Churchill notamment et plusieurs
autres comme nous le dit Nabih
Alexandre Chartier.
- Stars de cinéma, géants
de la politique ou sportifs
légendaires, Youssef Karsh
a photographié les plus grands
avec une sensibilité
et une maitrise incomparables.
IVANOH DEMERS, photographe
- C'est extraordinnaire
de découvrir ça aujourd'hui.
Techniquement, comme
photographe, voir ça,
ça s'invente pas. Regardez,
les poils qui lèvent
sur les bras.
- L'exposition "L'univers
de Youssuf Karsh - L'essence
du sujet" permet de découvrir
les 111 photographies que sa
veuve vient d'offrir au Musée
des beaux-arts de Montréal.
Un regard privillégié sur les
grandes figures du siècle
dernier.
MARY-DALEY DESMARAIS,
conservatrice en chef, MBAM
- Cette capacité de capter
l'essence du sujet, justement
cette phrase qui fait partie
du titre de l'exposition, qu'on
voulait présenter son travail
parce que c'est une exposition
qui est, à la fin, très, très
humaine.
- Youssuf Karsh a immigré seul
au Canada en 1908 pour fuir
le génocide arménien. C'est
cette photo de Winston Churchill
qui lui ouvre les portes
d'une carrière internationale.
- Moi, je veux pas la photo
avec le cigare, je veux l'avoir
qui me regarde puis il avait
un cigare tout le temps.
Il s'est approché, il a enlevé
le cigare. Quand on est
photographe, il faut qu'on soit
capable, la personne qui est
en avant de nous, lui faire
comprendre qu'on travaille
pour cette personne-là.
On veut montrer qui elle est.
- De grands Québécois aussi
ont posé pour lui, notamment
Jean-Paul Riopel
ou Gratien Gélinas.
- On voit des moments très
intimes, qui sont captés
dans chacune de ses images
et donc, il y a une chaleur
dans cette exposition
et une sorte d'intimité.
- Mais il aussi photographié
des ouvriers et des gens
ordinaires.
HILLIARD T. GOLDFARB,
conservateur sénior, MBAM
- Il a eu une manière de mettre
les sujets à l'aise et trouver
un moment tellement expressif.
Il était un grand humaniste.
Il a cherché d'exprimer
les relation entre les hommes
diverses.
- Les images sont accompagnées
de textes explicatifs
qui racontent, dans les mots
du photographe décédé en 2002,
ses rencontres avec ses sujets.
Les photographies
de Yousuf Karsh nous permettent
de regarder l'histoire
droit dans les yeux.
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M